plus de 200 personnes interrogées plus
de 60 expertise judiciaire et 542 haut
que j'ai saisi le ministère russe de
l'intérieur affirme que ce ne serait pas
une substance toxique qui serait à
l'origine du malaise d'alexis navale et
les pousses de navalni à informer les
médecins que son mari avait restreint
son alimentation est que pendant trois à
cinq jours il avait souffert d'une
sensation de malaise après les repas ces
prises de repas étant irrégulière son
épouse a également supposer que le
malaise pourrait avoir été provoqué par
un régime alimentaire du patient visant
à perdre du poids
après des études chimiques et
toxicologique répéter les médecins ont
établi le diagnostic final suivant
troubles du métabolisme des glucides
procréative chronique avait dit ce
fonctionnement des glandes exocrines et
endocrine puis complications le
ministère allemand de la justice affirme
que la russie n'a pas fourni toutes les
informations nécessaires qui concerne
l'incident la russie rétorque du 27 août
au 28 septembre
le parquet général de russie a transmis
quatre demandes des judiciaire dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur l'incident à
bord de l'avion reliant tomsk à moscou
30 octobre nous avons reçu la réponse
des autorités allemandes compétentes
contenant des demandes d'informations
supplémentaires sur l' enquête en cours
ladite réponse ne contient aucune
explication de fond sur les questions
posées par la russie
on regarde cette réponse constatons que
jusqu'à présent nos demandes n'ont pas
été satisfaites
en fait ce retard empêche les autorités
compétentes de la fédération de russie
de faire toute la lumière sur les
circonstances de l'incident
le manque de coopération de berlin a
aussi été dénoncé par la porte parole de
la diplomatie russe
le ministère fédéral allemand de la
justice
une annonce absolument rien de nouveau
vous ne fait qu'à dresser des contres
demande de temps confirmant que les
autorités à berlin refuse de fournir des
preuves matérielles de l'empoisonnement
de navettes par la fameuse substance nos
vies de choc cher tout comme les tests
biologiques
les résultats des examens dans ce
contexte nous tenons aussi à rappeler
que précédemment
après une demande de berlin toutes les
informations essentielles ont été
supprimées du rapport de l'organisation
pour l'interdiction des armes chimiques
sur la fourniture d'une assistance
technique à l'allemagne âges se sont
jadis tu vois des questions tout à fait
justifiée se pose et nous les avons
formulé à plusieurs reprises que cachent
nos collègues allemands
quels sont les faits qu'ils ne veulent
pas rendre publique la loggia chiwa agne
et akbar hayat
moscou espère qu'en fin de compte berlin
remplira ses obligations juridiques
internationales découlant de la
convention européenne d'entraidé
judiciaire en matière pénale la
diplomatie russe espère aussi que le
gouvernement d'angela merkel
s'abstiendra de toute politisation
artificielle de la situation qui nuit
sérieusement aux relations russo
allemandes